these are all of course fascinating and
striking themes but the most famous
aspect of this gospel by far is of
course the way that it talks about the
relationship between Jesus and Mary
Magdalene right um Mary just like in the
Gospel of Mary the gospel of philli
seems to portray her as being somehow
the favorite disciple of Jesus that
she's the sort of foremost disciple whom
he liked more than anyone else and who
whom he gave sort of the deepest truths
or the most full truth too in some way
quote the companion of the savior is
Mary of magdala the Savior loved her
more than all the disciples and he used
to kiss her often on her if this were
true along with the rest of the passage
which indicat that she was His companion
and that he loved her more than the
other disciples seemed to many to
indicate that Jesus and Mary Magdalene
had some kind of romantic relationship